a lot of my friends are moving
and i'm not i feel abandoned
wait a minute what on this show we've
talked about before adults can't be
abandoned we just want to remind you
guys
merge we just remember you have a car
i am open
to moving to another city so
we asked fans to send us videos
we didn't because we couldn't decide we
had a few options and there's
so amazing they're gonna try to convince
you to go so this is some of their
pitches
hi whitney hi benton um please ignore
the fact that i look like an uncombed
shih tzu right now
uh here's my pitch for the burlington
vermont area
how important is sunlight to you
not at all you're famous
nobody in vermont cares i don't know if
you can see them or not
but those are horses i don't know how
legal it is for me to be
on my neighbor's property filming that
right now so
i'm leaving people also really love and
respect animals around here it's
one of the really beautiful things about
vermont there you have it going to
vermont area
i'd give it a 7.2 of them
first of all i i'm not famous in vermont
and last time i was there someone
thought i was the lady from the
progressive commercial
oh she's famous i mean i mean i would
love to be in
this a place that has snow in seasons
especially if someone's walking around
dramatically going how important is the
sun
and then she's like i think i'm
trespassing i love her i love this
attitude honestly
7.8 i love that she's like
i'm not going to give it a 10 out of 10.
7.9 out of 10. she's like you know i
i'm here people from vermont like they
they like to manage your expectations
yeah she's the real selling point
i like her hi whitney my name is alison
in true whitney fashion and just stare
at this zit
on my facebook i'm trying to tell you
other information while also wearing
some sort of animal print and oddly dyed
hair um
so anyway i mean it's roasting i think
that's my daughter
i think benton would like it i feel like
nashville and austin are like
sister cities obviously they're not
exactly the same but we've got a similar
vibe going on
um i will buy you i left now one of
these
little outfits i have going on the
matching shoes
hang on if i can dress like that
i'll move to austin if i can wear
what she's wearing whitney please come
to austin
it would be amazing at the very least
come visit if i can dress in
full cheetah
while being a cougar i'm in yeah she was
amazing i did like that she was like
austin is a lot like nashville benton i
love nashville
just weird selling exactly like the
place that you left as
quickly as you could yeah she seems very
trendy and she seems
very in the know austin people seem to
be
having a good time she's got lights in
her apartment she's like
she's doubling down on the pandemic she
has the lights in her
putting lights up we're celebrating like
she's like doing the damn thing she
matched her hair to her outfit
i love her uh-oh um i'm gonna make my
case for coral gables
who's only i think that you should move
here
reason number one is because there's no
state tax i'm so worried there's gonna
be someone else in the bed
i'm just like is she naked
is she naked is she naked always
beautiful
you have the ocean um if i can live like
this
if i can just lay in bed all day are
these brook linen sheets
i just love it here and most people are
really happy here
so if i can get that skin i'll move
wherever she i would say
her skin is dewy as
hi whitney hi bente hey cutie
hi good for you oh that's all um
kelly and um
on places to live midwest
is i need a possibility because she's
definitely a theater kid
places to live hello
good for you podcast
this is not a this is not a telling us
where to move this is an audition
this is she is this fully auditioning
and i am here for it she's
in wicked tomorrow i live in
an amazing city this is me trying to do
an instagram story
so awkward we are the one of the most
obese cities in
indiana okay and we're like
the meth capital of indiana meth capital
of indiana
there's a t-shirt for that somewhere you
got your you got your neighbors to the
west of
illinois so you can still get your pot
this
isn't fake you got your neighbors i love
that she's doing a fake out
of kentucky you got all the hockeys down
there
you got your neighbor to the east of
ohio
she is full give my regards to broadway
remember me to herald square that's her
but her pitch for indiana is there's
other states you can go to also
yeah she's like but you can go to
chicago you can go to
she's just describing a map she's like
she's just telling you like
don't worry you can go to other places
from here but she's doing it with jazz
hand
you know what this reminds me of um uh
this is why i love robin so much
batman's partner no
the singer oh yeah robin her whole thing
is like i'm in the corner watching you
kiss her like
her whole thing is like i'm number two i
know that's her whole thing guys
why that's her entire life i just being
cheated on
over and over i like this indiana person
i like this indiana thing because she's
an underdog she's like i know my state
is an underdog
i know you're probably going to want to
go to chicago i know you're probably
going to want to go to somewhere cooler
but you can live here and you can drive
two hours and maybe get to canada the
idea of robin sitting in her mansion
like
underdog we're saying this like what the
you can get to orlando florida i'm
obsessed with her that's exactly it's
like she's something
why would you that's the voice you hear
on a disneyland ride yes she should be a
hostess the city of evansville
and even when she knows she's about to
stutter she
owns it thank you love her good night oh
and we're two and a half hours away from
nashville benton
that's what's up thanks good for you
keep your hands and feet inside the ride
at all times
hey whitney hey girl don't leave don't
leave jelly
don't leave la don't do it girl dye your
hair a new color
buy a new horse shirt i need to go back
to buy some horse earrings
rescue a new horse how do you know all
my moves how does she know all my moves
something different with your time
cali loves you girl and you got benton
her eyebrows are incredible i love
benton
yeah the rest of the world is not as
accepting of benton
as we are to be honest
she looks well red so i mean i have to
believe her i think that she's read a
lot of books i like that she's like um
maybe you could find him an addict to
hide him here's some reasons you should
stay in california
benton could die
they could beat him to death in the
street if we leave california or
people i didn't live in the middle of
the bible belt i feel like i've been in
in other states with you and you weren't
murdered
yeah look at me do you feel unsafe in in
other states
no i feel unsafe in the men's bathroom
we are we are here to advertise okay
can i get my point across to whitney
cummings we are here to
advertise no to me okay i am here to
advertise
this paranormal activity to new york
uh i'm very surprised or maybe i don't
know
if you've lived here before are we
watching a sex tape
oh i think that you
would thrive here you're kind of already
a new yorker
i'm not gonna lie i heard i've heard
nothing she said i've been so distracted
by that man
but i don't know what's happening but
they both have covet as far as i'm
concerned
that just looks like a covenant we'll
look in there and see literally
everything
everything new york this is new york has
everything the weather is
less
nice okay but if you love christmas she
hates new york
because misery loves coming i know i was
gonna say i can't tell
that's funny misery loves how many for
sure you want me to come into your
hovel with you right now she's in her
kitchen her bathroom and her bedroom
worst person to pitch new york to anyone
too
she will appreciate i don't know
move to new york i like this
we have to i feel like we're very
similar
in terms of our mental health
i think you should move to los angeles
but wait he's telling us to move to l.a
that's where i live i think that you
would like it for your horses too
because it's hot and nice outside all
the time
and i think there's more opportunity for
benton here
honestly also he sincerely does not know
that you live here
no he doesn't that's fair no he doesn't
how did he find you i mean i don't know
i don't i don't think he really uh knows
who i am frankly
not a fan it's no clue come to uh
sarasota florida
where we build walls on the side
of the interstate
instead of seeing beautiful nature
salt i don't even want to see nature
that is so
florida that is so exactly the truth
[Applause]
i like anywhere you like it i love it
you like it i love it